qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête de
vladimir poutine
il ya beaucoup de choses vous voulez les
clés pour le comprendre bien sûr le
premier je vais vous dire c'est un
enfant de la rue mais à 13 ans il aurait
dû aller en prison il est formé comme un
enfant de la rue à saint pétersbourg et
c'est presque dangereux parce que les
psychorigides
mais ils ne reculent pas il se bat
jusqu'au bout c'est quelqu'un qui était
sauvé par son coach deuxième clé il est
devenu champion de judo kazakhstan le
judo excellent exercice a pour l'heure
je vais vous dire
transforme comment vous dire il utilise
la force de l'adversaire pour rapporter
avec la victoire combinée les jeux d'eau
qu'un troisième clé c'est plus banal
pour vous dire l'espion vous avez reçu
l'autre jour
certaines routines poutine c'est un
espion
c'est un seul budget se prenait pour
james bond à la mer c'est vrai que il
n'a utilisé il utilise quand ils mènent
négociations j'étais vous avez dire j'ai
participé à beaucoup ce que ce sommet
est mon principe que mitterrand et merci
telle équilibre des intérêts lui c'est
qu'ils équilibrent de la fois des forces
et ça c'est à dire au fait c'est le
rapport de force et ça c'est celle et
vous voulez le comprendre il faut faire
ça après il ya des références
historiques il ya les prédécesseurs
vous savez il me rappelle pour vous dire
pourquoi ces envies sérieusement parlant
des mamans les plus dangereux de
l'histoire de l'humanité ça parce que on
assure qu'il veut la guerre froide et
maintenant c'est pire que la guerre
froide pendant la guerre froide il y
avait comment vous dire dans la
progestérone propagande mais à côté je
les ai tous connu me suggère gromyko
c'était les gens qui perd sérieux ce que
les gens qui gérait il y avait des
règles aujourd'hui plus de régler le
dernière pas qu'un accord je précise je
vous savez je suis bousillé parce que
moi j'ai fait tellement pour jeter
cofondateur le premier parti
démocratique pour la démocratie et
surtout pour cette europe / est vraiment
avec la sécurité est rien n'existe pas
un regard